et avec nous aujourd'hui parce qu'elle
Perrino bonjour Pascal merci d'être avec
nous politologue professeur et mérite à
l'Institut des titres politiques de
Paris Emmanuel a disons bonjour Emmanuel
ravi de vous retrouver grand reporter à
l'Obs et Steve et de retour également on
va parler rebonjours de cette dixième
journée de mobilisation moins suivie que
les précédentes à leurs bâton vers un
essoufflement de la mobilisation vous
nous le dirai et puis on va parler de
cette médiation proposée par Laurent
Berger pour sortir de la crise assez
vite rejetée par Olivier Véran et puis
dans la soirée on a appris qu'Elizabeth
borne aller avait invité les syndicats
l'Inter syndical à venir à Matignon la
semaine prochaine alors le dialogue
entre exécutif et syndicat peut-il être
noué Elisabeth borne peut-elle faire des
concessions sur sa réforme on verra ce
que vous en pensez d'abord on regarde
l'actualité dans nos régions
et on va parler de cette dixième journée
de mobilisation avec nos partenaires de
la presse régionale on va Orléans
retrouver Eric Richard bonjour Eric
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste à La Nouvelle République
Éric comment s'est déroulée cette
journée de mobilisation dans votre
région
dans le centre ouest comme ailleurs
c'est net pas de pas de scoop on marche
moins si je puis dire on en a eu
l'illustration hier où les cortèges
étaient visiblement bien moins dense à
l'occasion de cette dixième journée de
mobilisation par rapport à la précédente
alors sans vous noyer sous les chiffres
ainsi l'on prend l'exemple juste de la
manifestation à Orléans la préfecture de
Région Centre Val de Loire
6500 participants selon la préfecture ça
fait du monde certes mais c'est à peine
plus 2% de la population d'une
agglomération qui compte environ 300 000
habitants et puis dans ces cortèges on
l'a bien vu aussi la
les manifestants rajeunissent si l'on
peut dire davantage d'étudiants et de
lycéens dont beaucoup se disent
d'ailleurs solidaires de leurs parents
seulement voilà des parents justement
des pères et des mers de famille qui
était pourtant mobilisés depuis des mois
et bien on envoie moins ils sont
rattrapés c'est clair par les
contraintes en quelque sorte du pouvoir
d'achat bien mis à mal lui aussi
pourtant bien les manifestants hier
présent voulaient encore y croire ils
entendent être encore là en avril avec
l'espoir toujours chevillé au corps de
faire reculer le gouvernement sur son
projet de réforme des retraites en
sachant bien sûr que d'ici là et bien
les diverses tentatives de réouverture
du dialogue donneront peut-être des
résultats inattendus pour l'heure en
tous les cas on peut rêver
de bassine à Sainte-Soline dans les
Deux-Sèvres on en est au bilan des
incidents mais aussi aux explications de
part et d'autre
trois jours après ces affrontements
violents de sainte-soling il y a le
ministre de l'Intérieur si l'on peut
dire compte les points d'abord dans un
souci affiché de transparence le
ministre a publié hier sur son sur le
site internet donc du ministère de
l'Intérieur les rapports de la préfète
des Deux-Sèvres mais aussi ceux de la
gendarmerie des rapports qui font un
état précis selon eux des opérations
menées le 25 mars dernier par les
quelques 3200 gendarmes présents sur
place c'est une volonté de rompre en
quelque sorte avec l'opacité alors que
des polémiques on le sait sont apparus
qui mettent en évidence une dissonance
parfois entre la parole de l'État et le
constat d'un certain nombre
d'observateurs sur place dissonance sur
l'intervention des secours on le sait
qui aurait été retardé auprès des
blessés les plus brièvement
sur l'utilisation des lanceurs de balles
de défense par des quads de la
gendarmerie utilisation proscrite
d'abord démenti par Gérald de Darmanin
finalement admise le ministre devant
même préciser que les gendarmes
contrevenants seront sanctionnés cela
étant le ministre n'est pas en position
de victime vous en doutez il a aussi un
annoncé sa volonté de dissoudre le
groupe soulèvement de la terre groupe
considéré comme le principal Brandon de
la discorde sur place Gérald Darmanin a
dit aussi hier devant l'Assemblée qu'il
présenterait un décret donc de
on va revenir Eric parce qu'on a on a
des petits problèmes de connexion avec
vous on va regarder vos unes de choc
après sainte Soline et la mobilisation
marque le pas se c'est la ce sont les
une de la Nouvelle République merci
beaucoup
Eric Richard elle marque le pas Emmanuel
cette mobilisation on est sur un
essoufflement où on est sur une baisse
temporaire avec des hauts et des bas en
tout cas les marches classiques
contrôlées encadrées par des syndicats
clairement
semblent s'essouffler et ce qui est
assez logique au bout de 10 journées
c'est d'ailleurs on le sait bien en
partie le Paris du gouvernement après il
y a quelques éléments qu'on ne maîtrise
pas et qui fera surveiller c'est d'abord
les jeunes on avait annoncé leur venue
en masse hier ça n'a pas été le cas
il n'y en a néanmoins un peu plus et
surtout on sait que quand il le viennent
ils débordent c'est ce qui est arrivé la
semaine dernière avec ses échappées
nocturne beaucoup plus incontrôlable et
beaucoup plus dangereuse et on ne sait
pas dans quelle mesure c'est le signe
pourrait pas se reproduire à l'occasion
soit d'un autre un nouveau faut pas soit
de de vous savez qu'il y a aussi des
blessés de sainte Soline qui sont
surveillés de près par toute cette
population aussi voilà donc il faut pas
il faut pas il ne faut pas je pense
totalement aujourd'hui exclure cette
possibilité là et puis il y a ces
militants d'extrême gauche qu'on a vu à
l'oeuvre à Sainte Soline notamment et
qu'on a vu à l'oeuvre dans les courants
manifestations qui restent là évidemment
aussi en attente et en veille de d'une
possibilité de se réapparaître quoi donc
je je sans doute que la
marge classique en nombre en masse dans
les rues elle passe le pas en revanche
la possibilité d'avoir des débordements
autres existent toujours on va revenir
justement sur cette question des
violences sur cet essoufflement parce
qu'elle est-ce que le gouvernement est
en passe de gagner son pari
écoutez c'est le scénario un peu sur
toutes les réformes des retraites un
souvenez-vous dans les 6 ou 7 grandes
réformes de retraite depuis le début des
années 90 il y avait une mobilisation
importante il y avait une grève
d'opinion et ensuite il y avait une
usure là on a on avait la pression
pouvait avoir l'impression que l'usure
ne venait pas il y a les premiers signes
d'usure mais la mobilisation reste à un
niveau élevé mais il y a les premiers
signes d'usure on le voit en effet moins
de monde dans les manifestations et quel
que soit le terrain même dans ces
fameuses ville moyenne deuxième
indicateur le taux de grève le taux de
grève est extrêmement faible il y a même
des secteurs ou pourtant d'habitude il y
a un pourcentage de grévistes importants
je pense au monde enseignant et bien là
on était en dessous de 5% de grévistes
donc c'est un indicateur là aussi d'un
signe d'un signe d'affaiblissement et
puis dans les enquêtes d'opinion qui
posent les mêmes questions environ
chaque semaine là aussi il y a décrue ça
reste un haut niveau il est encore une
majorité absolue de Français qui sont
contre la réforme des retraites qui
soutiennent la mobilisation mais par
exemple chez dans le sondage Harris
Interactive il y a eu un une perte de 7
points dans le soutien à la mobilisation
donc on voit bien qu'il y a différents
signes est-ce que le pari du
gouvernement est gagné non pas encore
parce qu'il faut que le gouvernement
maintenant envoie des signes pour
nourrir cette décrispation s'il n'envoie
pas de signe fort et d'actes forts pour
nourrir cette décrispation on risque
d'avoir jusqu'à l'été une grogne qui
s'entretient et on va en parler de ce
pas peut-être qu'a fait Elisabeth
bornière est-ce que vous Emmanuel qui
suivez ces mobilisations de très près
est-ce que vous sentez chez les
manifestants qui sont encore nombreux
parce que à raison de le dire une forme
de fatigue de résignation
alors une forme de fatigue oui de
résignation patente c'est à dire que
beaucoup disent on continuera
il y a il y a cette vraiment cette
colère profonde au-delà de la retraite
c'est-à-dire que ce 49-3 marqué un
tournant dans les esprits avec avec
l'idée quand même que que le
gouvernement
n'a pas écouté la rue et a été au-delà
de ce qu'il le fait pas même le jeu
parlementaire ça a beaucoup marqué les
esprits y compris chez les jeunes qui
pourraient qu'on pouvait penser plus
loin de ces questions et notamment des
questions de retraite effectivement mais
le 49-3 c'est quelque chose qui revient
vraiment en boucle dans les
manifestations plus que que la retraite
et donc dans dans les gestes attendus je
pense qu'il y a aussi une manière de
gouverner différentes
et je pense que c'est important dans les
semaines à venir alors il y a cette
rencontre proposée par Isabelle borne
au-delà de ça il va y avoir vraiment je
pense la nécessité pour le gouvernement
d'avoir une attitude beaucoup plus
conciliante et à l'écoute parce que
parce que on sent qu'il y a une
population qui est très très en veille
sur cette question et uniquement sur la
réforme des retraites parce qu'on a
l'impression que les la mobilisation
elle a un peu changé de nature aussi au
début c'était très concentré évidemment
sur la réforme des retraites là on a
l'impression que c'est concentré sur un
peu autre chose ça s'élargit si une
contestation plus générale oui c'est une
contestation plus générale dans
l'opinion dans la mobilisation et on le
voit avec les jeunes en effet les jeunes
certes ils peuvent être préoccupés par
l'avenir des retraites mais enfin
j'espère pour eux que ce n'est pas tout
de même l'essentiel de leur de leur
préoccupations et on voit bien que
derrière la crise sociale il y a aussi
une crise politique c'est-à-dire une
crise sur le leadership démocratique
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un leadership
dans une démocratie et là il y a oui un
style d'exercice du pouvoir qui est
fortement contesté fortement contesté
par les jeunes fortement contestés par
qui se sont mobilisés dans le mouvement
social et il y a la recherche et c'est
un des problèmes d'ailleurs d'Emmanuel
Macron depuis le début depuis son
élection en 2017
parce que il avait promis aux Français à
la fois un style certes jupitérien alors
là les Français sont servis mais il
avait promis aussi un style plus
horizontal de concertation et puis il
l'avait répété dans la campagne de 2022
je gouvernerai autrement et là il faut
bien le dire les Français sont
extrêmement déçus et en particulier les
personnes qui sont dans la rue les
jeunes qui se disent on voit très bien
l'aspect jupitérien on le condamne parce
que c'est pas leur style d'exercice de
l'autorité mais voilà ils attendent
toujours le deuxième Macron
a été confronté à une crise historique
et de celle des gilets jaunes où on lui
a beaucoup reproché de ne pas avoir su
sentir la population son létale la
France
le peuple et et finalement on se rend
compte qu'il a réagit la même manière
cette fois-ci et c'est vrai que comme
s'il n'avait pas appris finalement des
erreurs précédentes il faut se souvenir
que pour son sa première élection il
avait parlé de démocratie participative
il avait parlé de mettre des outils en
place donc cette attente finalement elle
est connue on sait que c'est un problème
de fond de que la notamment l'abstention
vient aussi de de ce sentiment que on ne
peut plus participer finalement aux jeux
politiques politiques pardon et donc il
y a cette attente qui est profonde qui
est connue et finalement 6 ans après on
se rend compte que ça n'est toujours pas
inscrit est-ce que du coup on est en
train de passer de manifestations qui
étaient très syndicalisées à des
manifestations qui deviennent très
politisées alors dès le début dans ces
manifestations quand on interrogé les
gens on parlait retraites et on parlait
du reste vraiment ce malaise
démocratique il existe et il s'exprime
depuis le début simplement aujourd'hui
il est encore plus fort parce que c'est
49-3 a vraiment
mis ça en premier plan et de fait il y a
des personnes syndiquées dans ces
manifestations et dès qu'on sort de ces
manifestations officielles de la journée
on se retrouve le soir avec une
population qui n'a plus rien à voir avec
les syndics et le fait l'annonce
Elisabeth borne qui a dit désormais je
n'utiliserai plus le 49-3 hors-taxe
budgétaire est-ce que ça ça peut être
une réponse ou ça ne résonne pas dans
l'esprit des manifestants et des
Français
c'est une réponse dont je doute
d'ailleurs parce que l'article 49 alinéa
3 revues et corrigée profondément en
2008 par la réforme Sarkozy c'est un
instrument démocratique de la
Constitution alors on peut en contester
son usage ensuite mais il a été utilisé
en la répéter je ne sais combien de fois
100 fois sous la 5e République et c'est
un peu bizarre pour une chef de
gouvernement de dire bah voilà je ne
leur réutiliserai pas ce qui est assez
dangereux d'ailleurs quand on il vous
manque 40 députés dans la majorité pour
atteindre la majorité absolue bon je me
sens la utiliser que sur des textes
budgétaires elle a utilisé que sur
l'intégration
on verra on verra si le Conseil
constitutionnel est d'accord sur
l'utilisation sur la réforme des
retraites bon on verra
de la procédure je ne sais pas si si
c'est une réponse à la hauteur du défi
en revanche faire un geste vers le
mouvement syndical vers l'Inter syndical
et d'ailleurs c'est lié à ce que
pourrait dire le Conseil constitutionnel
si le Conseil constitutionnel invalide
une partie de la réforme vous voyez bien
que va se réouvrir un espace pour le
débat un espace pour la négociation le
gouvernement peut faire autrement qu'il
l'a fait dans un premier temps et donc
tous les espoirs d'ajustement de le fait
de renouer le débat démocratique
j'allais dire normal tout ça et
peut-être dans un avenir et un avenir
assez proche puisque le Conseil
constitutionnel a été saisi en urgence
et c'est un espoir sachez les
manifestants cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel
en fait il n'en parle pas donc peut-être
que ça reste encore un peu trop
théorique tout ça
je pense aussi que je pense vraiment
qu'ils attendent de du pouvoir lui-même
en fait
des gestes et des de changement de de
direction en fait et de de d'exercices
du pouvoir or le Conseil constitutionnel
finalement c'est une c'est un conseil
autre c'est un qui va sanctionner le
pouvoir donc c'est un petit peu indirect
vous voyez comme évolution sans doute
que ça va peut-être et
l'esperton un petit peu calmé la
situation mais encore une fois ce qui a
attendu de l'exercice du pouvoir
aujourd'hui c'est un message très très
fort qui est mieux pensé de crise et il
faut vraiment qu'il soit entendu parce
que sinon les crises reviendront d'une
autre manière c'est-à-dire qu'on a eu
les gilets jaunes on a eu la réforme des
retraites et on aura autre chose tant je
pense tant qu'il en fait vraiment de
changement profond de cette de cet
exercice du pouvoir qui aujourd'hui est
obsolète on l'entend beaucoup dans les
manifestations et on va parler de cette
possible sortie de crise mais il y a
quelque chose qui vient dans le débat
politique c'est la stratégie du maintien
de l'ordre et des violences lors de ces
manifestations et Gérald Darmanin est en
première ligne de la table notamment
pointé du doigt pour les événements de
Sainte-Soline on en parlait tout à
l'heure ça ne souligne le weekend
dernier on rappelle que la manifestation
organisée contre les bassines ou les
méga bassines dans les Deux-Sèvres
avaient été interdites par la préfecture
6000 personnes qui sont quand même
rassemblées selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur face à eux plus de 3000
gendarmes et policiers ont été mobilisés
des affrontements rapidement éclaté
bilan 47 gendarmes blessés dont deux
hospitalisés les organisateurs parlent
eux de 200 blessés côté manifestants
donc 40 grièvement avec deux pronostics
vitaux engagés sur ce plateau Sandrine
Rousseau a accusé Gérald Darmanin de
provocation écouter là
il y a une responsabilité dans le
maintien de l'ordre dans cette
manifestation et en fait il y a une
responsabilité du pouvoir politique
c'est une intimidation une politique de
l'intimidation et moi je me demande dans
quelle mesure il n'y a pas de la part de
Gérald Darmanin et d'Emmanuel Macron la
volonté de d'aller chercher l'incident
et Ramadan
nationale Gérald de Darmanin a rappelé
que la manifestation avait été interdite
par les autorités il a annoncé dans la
foulée la dissolution d'un collectif
écologiste à l'origine du rassemblement
l'association les soulèvements de la
terre et puis toujours lors de ces mêmes
questions d'actualité le ministre de
l'intérieur a été interpellé sur la
question plus générale des violences
policières alors que ce déroulait au
même moment la dixième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites en réponse à la députée
ancienne sénatrice écologiste Sophie
tailler polluant Gérald Darmanin a lancé
la charge contre la nups écoutez-le que
s'est
-il passé que s'est-il passé à gauche
pour qu'on n'est pas un mot dans une
question d'actualité pour penser à tous
ces policiers ces gendarmes qui sont
blessés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour publier lundi le recours aux
arrestations préventives des
arrestations arbitraires qui sont
illégales ils devront être question la
semaine prochaine à l'Assemblée
nationale puisqu'on a appris que Gérald
Darmanin sera auditionné par les députés
objets de l'audition gestion du maintien
de l'ordre et qui devient donc une
question très politique parce qu'elle a
avec la gauche qui est reproche à Gérald
Darmanin d'entretenir une forme de
stratégie du chaos oui oui on est au
coeur du un combat qui maintenant n'est
pas simplement le combat social de
manière évidente mais le combat
politique il s'agirait de présenter le
pouvoir
macronien comme étant plus qu'un pouvoir
jupitérien mais un pouvoir autoritaire
un pouvoir policier un pouvoir répressif
alors on verra la marge de manœuvre que
ce type de campagne peut avoir dans
l'opinion publique mais c'est à double
tranchant parce que l'opinion publique
se rend compte aussi que dans les
manifestations là où il y a le plus de
essés cet en général parmi les forces de
l'ordre que ce soit la gendarmerie ou la
police donc en effet certains
manifestants bien sûr ce sont
heureusement d'un film minorité certains
manifestants viennent manifester avec
d'autres objectifs c'est évident que de
se plaindre du style d'exercice du
pouvoir du Président de la République ou
de sa réforme des retraites
un rebute les manifestants c'est
violence ça les inquiète les
manifestants traditionnelles évidemment
alors ce qui est étonnant en fait depuis
le début de ce mouvement c'est que
presque tous les gens qu'on interroge
quand on leur parle de la violence ils
disent bah moi peut-être pas mais moi je
pense qu'elle est nécessaire donc il y a
quand même cette idée notamment que les
gilets jaunes ont obtenu quelque chose
grâce à la violence une idée d'ailleurs
qui risque de s'inscrire encore puisque
finalement là il y a eu de la violence
et il y a un début de mouvement du
gouvernement donc c'est quelque chose
qui avance par ailleurs j'aurais quand
même dire que sur ce que ce que vous
venez de de soulever il y a le le seul
essence de l'exercice du pouvoir dont je
parlais quand on regarde là on veut
interdire des manifestations
quand elles sont illégales sauf que on
se rend compte aujourd'hui depuis les
gilets jaunes que c'est de plus en plus
une forme de de d'exercice aussi de la
rue qui fonctionne en tout cas qui est
qui est utilisé par par des gens parce
qu'on estime que les marches légales
justement ne sert pas à grand chose on
veut interdire une association
écologiste on dit juste en disant ben on
va on va la dissoudre on sait très bien
qu'il suffit de changer de nom et elle
va recommencer on veut interdire les
mouvements de rue du soir en
interpellant des centaines de
manifestants c'est à dire en essayant de
les effacer de la rue mais c'est pas ça
qui va arrêter les mouvements et on voit
bien que dans ces volontés de simplement
de manière très verticale dire bon bah
ça on en veut pas on va faire en sorte
que ça n'existe plus ça ne fonctionne
plus vous parliez Emmanuel de cette
porte ouverte en tout cas vers une
sortie de crise hier par Elizabeth Borg
qui a invité l’inter syndicale à
Matignon la semaine prochaine on va voir
ce qu'on pense Laurent Berger le
secrétaire général de la CFDT en vitesse
matin de France Info
et vous imaginez bien qu'alors que on
est à la dixième journée mobilisation
qui mobilise encore beaucoup de gens
qu'on est dans un moment de contestation
très fort dans le pays sur cette réforme
des retraites les représentants des
organisations syndicales de ce pays vont
pas aller discuter avec la première
ministre d'autres choses on va aller
discuter des retraites moi j'irai on dit
en expliquant pourquoi c'est très fort
mais tu n'as pas pourquoi elle recueille
autant de contestations pourquoi elle
est injuste et pourquoi faut trouver une
porte de sortie qui ne soit pas le
pourrissement de parier comme on peut
l'imaginer aujourd'hui de la part du
gouvernement sur le pourrissement d'un
mouvement social qui n'arrivera pas ce
qu'il faut qu'on comprenne c'est qu'il y
a profond rejette cette réforme et un
ressentiment dans le monde du travail
aujourd'hui sur la façon des choses se
passent alors visiblement il va y avoir
rencontre mais est-ce qu'il pourra y
avoir dialogue entre des syndicats qui
ne veulent discuter de la réforme des
retraites et de la question du report de
l'âge et Franck Riester qui était sur ce
plateau il y a quelques minutes et qui
disait mais c'est le cœur de la réforme
on reviendra pas là-dessus on parlera du
reste oh non ça va être difficile mais
remarquez qu'ils y vont voilà c'est déjà
déjà un premier pas parce que il y
aurait une autre solution c'est à dire
le refus de répondre à lavitation donc
en ce qui concerne leur berger mais je
crois que Philippe Martinez a dit
éventuellement aussi qu'il pourrait s'y
rendre ils iront donc on verra ensuite
le dialogue risque d'être si les
syndicalistes restent sur la ligne que
Laurent Berger définit ça risque de
durer quoi un quart d'heure on verra si
ça dure plus d'un quart d'heure
on sait qu'Elizabeth borne est très
douée dans dans les discussions la
prouvé auparavant pas avant dans dans
ses fonctions de ministre en revanche la
situation est quand même extrêmement
inédite et très tendue et j'imagine mal
des syndicats acceptés de parler
d'autres choses que du coeur de ce qui
constitue la crise actuelle évidemment
quelle peut être la solution vous nous
parlez de cette volonté des manifestants
d'avoir plus de démocratie un nouveau
processus
démocratique est-ce que c'est l'unique
solution
alors il peut y en avoir d'autres à
court terme on le sait il y a le Conseil
constitutionnel il y a le référendum
d'initiative partagé qui a été lancé par
par les filles et qui domine d'avoir 4
millions de de qui était une forte
demande des gilets jaunes exactement
tout à fait donc
il peut à court terme il peut y en avoir
d'autres à long terme il ne peut pas y
avoir d'autres solutions qu'un
changement profond de l'exercice du
pouvoir sinon on continuera d'avoir ces
crises violentes et pas et ponctuel mais
qui en fait représente un malaise
vraiment qu'ils de fond c'est à dire
qu'on est dans un monde où la
verticalité ne fonctionne plus on est
dans un monde où on demande de plus en
plus d'horizontalité dans tout dans les
rapports au travail dans les rapports au
sein des familles
le pouvoir doit aussi s'imprégner de
cette nouvelle demande c'est-à-dire que
évidemment tout le monde ne peut pas
être président de la République on est
bien d'accord mais il y a un déficit en
termes de de démocratie participative
dans ce pays qui est réel qui était un
malaise exprime par les gilets jaunes
faut quand même se souvenir qu'ils ont
commencé sur le prix à la pompe et ils
ont fini sur le RIC et vous voyez des
réflexions qui étaient vraiment des
réflexions de vraiment d'organisation
politique donc là de nouveau on est face
à cette demande et cette crise ce 49-3
là encore cristallisé il faut vraiment
que les politiques se rendent compte de
ça parce que sinon on va on le sait très
bien déjà par une abstention encore plus
grande et des votes encore plus extrêmes
ouais mais est-ce que la parole
politique est encore crédible auprès des
français et notamment de ces
manifestants parce qu'elle est-ce qu'il
y a pas un vrai rejet de la classe
politique dans son ensemble c'est le
gros problème c'est à dire qu'on est
arrivé à un tel niveau de crise de la
démocratie de crise de confiance
dans le système politique ça dépasse
même le personnel politique que il est
très difficile aujourd'hui de résoudre
les crises parce que vous avez d'un côté
un président relativement isolé de
l'autre côté des millions de Français
atomisés en colère qui se réunissent de
temps en temps de manière éphémère dans
des manifestations et il n'y a rien
entre les deux c'est un paysage à peu
près désert que les pour l'instant le
front syndical s'efforce d'occuper mais
tout ça a été fait mère dans les
derniers sondages même sur que Sciences
Po a fait sur les Français et leur
représentants les représentants
syndicaux il faut savoir que les
syndicats ne sont pas très populaires
non plus ne font pas l'objet d'une
confiance extraordinaire nous avons un
pays dans lequel 8%, un des salariés
sont syndiqués donc c'est très difficile
de renouer un dialogue démocratique dans
ce type d'espace il faut vér simplement
que le pouvoir en effet je partage ce
qui vient d'être dit que le pouvoir
évolue dans sa manière de l'exercer ce
pouvoir au fond le message originel de
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est de dire voilà
j'ai gagné parce que je représentais un
nouveau monde il faut et voilà alors il
a détruit il a beaucoup contribué à
détruire le vieux monde mais sur ce tas
de ruines du vieux monde il faut faire
sentir aux Français qu'il y a à un
nouveau monde parce que si c'est
toujours le même style d'autorité
verticale qui vient d'en haut sans
véritable explication etc ça ne marchera
pas et est-ce que ce nouveau monde il
peut être incarné par Emmanuel Macron à
Emmanuel anison ou le rejet d'Emmanuel
Macron est-il trop fort auprès des au
sein des manifestants mais certes il y a
un sentiment de trahison en fait
profonde puisqu'effectivement il a été
quand il est arrivé il est cessé
incarner ce nouveau monde et
dans sa façon d'exercer le pouvoir il ne
l'incarne pas donc
il a traversé des crises absolument
historiques où il a montré qu'ils ne
savait pas écouter aujourd'hui il
apparaît plus solitaire que jamais il a
quand même eu un pays entier qui lui a
dit à la fois par les marches dans la
rue parlez sondages le Parlement
lui-même que ce cette réforme n'allait
pas et qu'il fallait
évoluer dans dans l'attitude et dans la
dans la façon de discuter il ne l'a pas
fait alors aujourd'hui effectivement il
a l'air de dire bah ça y est j'ai gagné
quand on parle de faction de factieux
enfin son discours a été extrêmement mal
ressenti par par la population on a
l'impression qu'il n'arrive pas du tout
à changer de bracket
la haine en plus ce qui est inquiétant
c'est que il y a une il y a une vraiment
une une haine de de d'Emmanuel Macron
qui s'est développée depuis les gilets
jaunes
auprès d'une partie de la population qui
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est pas une
haine en tout cas c'est une défiance et
des gens qui ont voté Emmanuel Macron
j'en ai rencontré dans ces
manifestations aujourd'hui sont vraiment
très remontés contre lui et puis il y a
aussi quand on voit la façon dont il y a
eu ces attaques de permanence et même de
mairie ce qui est inédit parce que le
maire jusqu'ici est quand même une
figure complètement privilégiée et quand
on voit qu'il y a même eu des attaques
de mairie ça c'est vraiment nouveau je
trouve que je me semble qu'il a en plus
contribué à ce que cette défiance gagne
tout le monde politique
on est dans une situation où il n'y a
plus beaucoup de de liens de lien au
travers d'organisation
même en effet les pouvoirs locaux
aujourd'hui sont contestés la violence
contre les mers c'est-à-dire quand il
n'y a plus corps intermédiaires
qu'est-ce qui s'installe la
brutalisation de la société et c'est ce
à quoi nous assistons brutalisation
sociale brutalisation politique et il y
a
urgence non pas de réinventer des corps
intermédiaires comme ça parce que des
corps intermédiaires ça s'établit pas
j'allais dire en l'espace d'une semaine
ça demande des années pour reconstruire
ce tissu mais au moins de renouer
[Musique]
dans l'espace public un dialogue avec
les forces qui tentent de représenter ce
qu'on appelle ce mouvement social on
continue à parler de cette journée de
mobilisation c'est évidemment la ligne
de vos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
Steve et de 10 oui 10e journée de
mobilisation hier contre la réforme des
retraites le nombre de manifestants on
en parle il y a quelques instants
étaient en baisse un peu partout en
France par rapport à la semaine dernière
mais la Marseillaise a vu dans les
cortèges une belle énergie c'est à la
Une de votre quotidien ce matin
reportage sur le terrain à Marseille
Arles Toulon et Avignon dans la foulée
des manifestations l'intersédicales a
appelé à une 11e journée de grève ce
sera jeudi prochain 6 avril et peut-être
que d'ici là gouvernement est syndicats
ont repris le dialogue oui peut-être un
premier pas à titre Midi Libre qui met
en une Elizabeth borne et le leader de
la CFDT Laurent Berger a rendez-vous et
donc prévu en début de semaine prochaine
à Matignon entre les syndicats et la
première ministre la date n'est pas
encore arrêtée l'ordre du jour n'a pas
été communiqué mais le dialogue devrait
pourrait enfin être relancé savoir si la
CGT sera effectivement de la partie
alors que la centrale syndicale doit
lire une nouvelle direction en fin de
semaine il y a eu des violences dans le
cortège oui la presse régionale s'en
fait largement l'écho ce matin la
violence
cran titre l'Ardennais à
Charleville-Mézières en marge d'un
défilé de 5000 personnes qui s'est
déroulées dans le calme les
affrontements ont éclaté près de l'hôtel
de ville pendant trois heures des
casseurs sans son prix aux forces de
l'ordre il y a eu une vingtaine
d'interprétations on finit sans
transition par une bonne nouvelle pour
les fidèles chrétiens oui c'est un
come-back le come-back de la tunique qui
aurait appartenu au Christ le quotidien
l'éco il dit que la sainte unique est
vraiment aucune transition c'est très
vite presse le quotidien l'écoute la
sainte tunique va de nouveau être
exposée en 2025 c'est ce qui a annoncé
l'évêque de Pontoise qui explique
l'exposition se déroulera à la basilique
d'Argenteuil la tunique que le Christ
aurait porté pendant le chemin de croix
est conservé dans cette basilique depuis
1200 ans la dernière fois qu'elle a été
présentée au public c'était en 2016
rendez-vous compte et c'était important
de vous parler de cet événement merci
beaucoup
c'est la République enlisée avec
Emmanuel Macron elle a une merci
beaucoup Emmanuel anison merci Pascal on
se retrouve demain à 15h séance de
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement au
Sénat et puis à 18h Thomas Hugues sens
public très bonne journée à demain
[Musique]